Van life lesson number six:
A self-build van conversion is never done and that's okay.
Once we finished installing our new bed and packed up all of our belongings,...
...we had to say goodbye to Alfie and the donkeys.
Our time in the mountains was over, but the van build wasn't quite done yet.
Every morning, we'd unload our supplies and keep building...
...and in the evenings, pack it back into the front of the van.
I sewed us door covers and blackout curtains, while Lou tinkered with the electrics.
Weeks later, we found our own little paradise on a secluded beach near Gibraltar,...
...where Lou rewired our lights and added in switches.
In a parking lot in Peniche, Portugal,...
...we added a vent above our kitchen, which has been a total game changer.
In all honesty, we have never stopped tinkering with this van.
One of the most empowering parts of this entire van conversion...
...is the fact that now when something isn't working,...
...we feel confident enough to fix the problem ourselves.
Ody may never be perfect, but he's a beautiful home for us.